hey y'all it's ender couch here and this
tattoo is a video
we're going to be going over how to
connect to a database using r and r
studio
so um what's cool about rstudio is it
comes with a lot of um
little features that allows you to
connect to a database very
fast um i'm actually going to create a
database
using a some data from my
current site project which is a ufc
sports betting model
so i wrote some functions to basically
do some web scraping
which will essentially scrape um all the
ufc
fights and the fight data um in ufc
history
i also had a lot of uh data cleaning too
so i figured that'd be cool to use kind
of like our
raw data and put it into a database and
kind of do some sql
um one thing that i have to say too is
that the database i'm creating
is gonna be a very simple database
and when you're actually gonna be
connecting to your database using an
odbc
um say in your work uh you'll probably
have to do a user id and password
probably have to establish like the
driver host schema
but that's stuff that you're probably
not to just ask the dba
or your other colleagues i also will say
that i use
the keyring package to secure my
credentials so that way um
when i'm sharing scripts or posting them
no one can see my
my you know vulnerable information
so we're just going to load up a r
studio uh load up our studio
put up our markdown calls tidy tuesday
database
open it up clear the garbage and then
load in the
tidy verse odbc package
uh dbi and i'm also loading the
r sql lite package so i can create a
database
for this working example i'm going to
load in the
fight data so i'm going to say read csv
fight data dot csv you look at it
and we have about 11 000 rows where
each row represents a fighter
and his or her respective fight with
their given data
so as you can see we have extract
received weight class time uh
significant strike percent all this
really interesting stuff that
would be good for creating creating like
a model
i'm now going to create our connection
so generally when you're connecting to a
database you always call it con
and then you do db connect uh in this
case i'm going to do sqlite
sqlite using r sqlite to create a
database i'm going to store it in memory
okay and then i copy this table to
copy the fight table to my you know
database in memory
great
so when you're kind of looking at a
table the first thing you kind of do is
uh select star
so i'm going to say dbget query uh
you have to give it the connection
and then i'm gonna write in select
star from fight
and now we have essentially a screenshot
of our fight table
okay so one thing when i'm looking at
this fight table is
uh oops is we kind of want to count how
many
fight bks or how many fighters there are
for every fight
so that's going to be a simple account
so db get quick oops
db get query con
and then select uh fight pk
count fight pk
from fight group by uh
fight okay and i'm also gonna order it
by count fight decay
in descending order just to make sure we
have two
uh fighters for every fight which makes
sense because i created this data
and it would be odd to have a fighter
having no opponent great
so that's good and all and if we
actually look at our table
um it's not really great for creating
say
a model because realistically what we'd
want is like a head-to-head
so i would want say stipe miyotic and
his opponent to be on the same row
which is a very simple join using the
fight bk
so let's go over a basic join
wow i keep on doing the db connection rx
gets query
on so what we're going to do is
basically uh build it um iteratively so
what i like to do is first do the
baseline query which is
fight pk and the fighter
from fight and then what we want to do
is basically create kind of like a
pseudo opponent table
where it's basically going to be sucking
flight pk in the fighter
okay so i'm going to do join select
fight pk fighter as
opponent from fight so this
essentially opponent table um oh that we
just created needs to be named
because we're gonna be joining it so i'm
gonna just call it b now what we're
gonna do is join the
fight table with the b table what i'm
gonna say is on
fight dot fight pk is equal to b
dot fight ek order
by fight pk
oops now what i have to do is also we
have ambiguous column name so i have to
specify it because we have
both a 5pk in the b table and the
fightbk in the fight table so i'm going
to say
fight dot fight bk uh fight.fighter
and then b dot opponent
uh fight. oops and then fight.5k amen
so we can see we kind of have a problem
here for one thing since it's just
joining by fight bk
uh we can see that gerard is facing
gerard and we can't have that
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
say where
oops showing on we're gonna say um
where oops where fighter oops
fight dot fighter
not equal to b dot component
right so now we have uh only two do
uh one duplicate for each fight and it's
kind of a problem because
they're essentially flip-flopped so
gerard is facing uh tayla
and with taiwa or taylor is facing
gerard uh
a little trick is just say fighter is
greater than opponent
he's just saying that okay um whichever
one is like
in the closest alphabetical order or the
closest like
a we kept so that's kind of a good way
to just
filter out these like you know pairwise
combinations
great so we have this um another thing
i'm going to add is the fight.res
and with it fight.res i think it'd be
kind of useful
to convert this these losses and wins
for the fighter and do ones and zeros so
this can be another little
uh another little command which is which
will be a case one statement
so case one
fighter dot res is equal to
w then one else
zero and as i'll say uh
fight res fighter dot rez word
oops fight. so now we have our fighter
rez converted
our results from the fight into zeros
and ones we also do a sani check with
just a
fight.res just to make sure i i didn't
do anything wrong
which it makes sense
okay so that's pretty cool and all um
one
one additional feature that um our
markdown has is that
if you ever notice that when you're
writing your code chunks
there's an r in it what that actually
means is
in that code chunk it's trying to look
at that um whatever you're typing
as an r language you can also uh change
it to sql and establish your connection
and then you can just write out um
explicit sql
like that so i think this is a little
bit nicer
because that way you can for sure know
you know this is sql
and this is r and you don't have these
like crazy unhighlighted
um you know functions which is very
useful
okay additionally what you can do is you
can change the
output so output.bar is equal to df
and you see that there's no um like
message but if we look at our df
it basically outputted the query that we
wrote in sql
into a output variable called dataframe
which is very cool
okay so kind of throughout this short
video
um i was kind of assuming that you guys
know sql however a lot of times people
don't have the
um didn't have the classes
to be able to take an official sql class
and most of it was just learned online
so your sql skills might not be very
good
luckily um d works really well
with um the databases so let's show you
how to
basically write sql without knowing any
any of it
as long as you know dplyr you can
basically get away with not knowing sql
in our in our in our studio however i
would definitely recommend
to learn some sql because it's a pretty
easy language
and you get a lot of rewards and a lot
of value from just learning basic
um select star statements and uh joins
so what i'm going to do is basically
create a database or
a table icon and fight
and this will be basically the data
frame that we'll be clearing from which
will be
our database so we'll fight db
and again this again is a screenshot of
it i might see that
there's only a thousand rows when in
route we should have about
11 000 it's just because it's only gonna
take the first thousand rows whenever
you print something out
okay so let's actually copy let's let's
let's rewrite this query into a d plier
or uh dpyr pipe r style title for syntax
what you would do is select fighter
fight pk right and then what you do is
uh
left join by database select
fight pk fighter and then opponent
is equal to fighter i equals fight pk
oops and i also want to do the uh was it
res
so we have that which is you know a
pretty pretty standard um
like you know pipe function or pipeline
then what we can do is we can say filter
fighter is not equal to opponent
and fighter is greater than opponent
and then what we can do is mutate res is
equal to if else
whereas is equal to w then it's a one
else it's a zero
so that's basically what we wanted uh
what we can do now is
cause a like fight query
and with this fight query
uh we can do show query and this will
basically create
the sql function or our our
the sql command uh for our table
all right so now what we could do is
just kind of copy this in
and brighten like you know sql
connection equals con
and i'll do that right so now we have it
um it's gonna
only show the first thousand but that's
fine
okay so that's pretty great
um what i'm always gonna do is i'm just
gonna use uh the thing that we created
so
which is the df but one thing that we
always have to do is when you're done
uh using the database you always should
use the db disconnect function
with the con and then specify your
connection
okay and what i'm gonna do is basically
an ewo
thing so since we have our pairwise
our our head to heads i can use the elo
package and create a generic evo model
so elo model and then elo dot
run was it fight res
fighter plus opponent
data equals df k equals 20.
now we have our elo model
ooh actually maybe i should probably
close my connection to the uh
itv too
okay nope we don't need to worry about
that cool
okay so now we have this data frame of
our eo history
what i can do now is just say like
select
i got team dot a and then
elo dot a rename all
uh dot fonts oops dot
funds is equal to ser replace
dot x dot a dot dot right
nothing too crazy uh put that in
dot b dot b
then dot b find rose
oop and there
so now that we have our output of our
query we can kind of combine this into
our elo model
and then output it out um oh actually i
should also do what is it
fight ek
oops um
yolo model as that data frame
oh yeah and then sorry i'll also just do
a little
bind columns and then say
df select
fight pk just so we have a fight bk that
reference
it
oops let's hear
okay so now we have that uh well we can
oops
um let's see here i'm gonna just
let's see here do that
do that okay there we go and then what
i'm gonna do is like a group
by uh was it team
arranged by fight pk
um
what
group by team
what's going on i just said what's going
on here
okay let's see your finding
rename all
okay
okay and then group by team right and
then
arrange by fight okay
um add their fight number which will be
their row number
so byte number is equal to
row
number
ungroup it and then we can gg plot like
the elo distributions for all the fights
so x equals
right number y equals ewo group is equal
to team
plus gm line alpha is equal to 0.4
and now we can kind of see the walk of
like all of our ego scores so
you know whoever right here was really
just beating everyone who was down here
basically
was losing against everyone and probably
got cut and we have it through all the
fight numbers so
you know the as as as the more fights
you do the more likely you're going to
kind of regress
down so that's basically it i know this
pretty fast video but i'll see you guys
next week and tidy on